yes yes yes barbecue always say yes a
lot of folks getting ready to host a
Fourth of July Gathering and for many
people that does mean barbecue you want
to make sure you do it right and the way
to do it right is get it from Soul belly
barbecue they're here with what they
have going on Richard how are you doing
man one of the partners I'm great great
thanks for having us Richard camarata
from Seoul belly is here with a
beautiful brisket and some amazing ribs
I know you know plenty about brisket and
barbecue side you know we'll get you to
see them that's right yeah he asked me
just before we went on he said you wanna
you wanna eat this I mean yeah yes yes I
do it's a picture
so yeah we have a great weekend coming
up we're really excited you can do
takeout packages with us we have all
sorts of things that you can find online
on our website Soul ballet bbq.com uh
barbecue is a great thing for takeout
reheats at home really yeah it does uh
you know if you don't want to do all the
work and all the meats do spending all
the time in front of the grill and a hot
summer day come pick up the meat from us
and then you can do some sides at home
but we can do all of it for you if you'd
like as well what I love about your
story is that you guys opened up with a
challenge right off the bat you opened
in May of 2020 right yep that's
incredible yeah and and yet here you are
thriving and you become so popular and
and the word is really good on the
street About Soul belly uh it's been
great man it's been a good couple years
uh we had to celebrate our first year
anniversary uh last May and uh it's been
a really fun time it's kind of a unique
place we do live music uh three four
nights a week plus a great food menu so
it's a space where you can use it in
many different ways yeah get down to our
Main Street yep mainstream the art
system and then what kind of music you
got going we're seeing some of it now
yeah so uh we do a variety it's it's
usually all in that kind of rock and
roll from some blues some Bluegrass you
know everything that kind of fits with
that kind of classic guitar feel a
little bit of honky tonk uh you know but
we we've had a couple different accents
you said three nights a week what nights
are there uh Friday Saturday and Sunday
mornings we usually do a show and then
sometimes on Sunday nights as well so
okay you know it changes a little bit
all the time but you know we like to mix
it up that's great can people go to your
website and see what's what we do we
have all the acts up on the website
everything's available on
soulbellybarbecue.com and then also on
our Instagram which is uh Soul valleybbq
LV awesome all right tell us what makes
a good brisket how do you know you got a
good brisket oh here you gotta you gotta
have a little bite yes I will yeah yeah
yeah thank you so it's all about the
mixture of uh you know lean and fat
there's nothing special about brisket
when it comes to seasoning or anything
like that all that's on this brisket
right here is salt and black pepper my
new friend my new buddy so Richard
you're the man black is good and then we
put these in the smoker so we start ours
in the morning and they'll finish up
usually around midnight so these have
been on the smoker anywhere between 14
to 16 hours depending on the size and
that's really what it's about and so you
got what this is called the the so to
speak fatty side if you're coming in
that's me say you want fatties yeah kind
of pieces you're getting people start
shopping fatty when I walk in it
convince me but I like it and it's just
a little bit you know fatty doesn't mean
it's you know no no I hate it and then
this is your lean side so it really is
uh it's something where you know what's
so good about this this really this is
good brisket and and I if I were if I
just sort of liked it I'd say hey that's
good but no I'm telling you this is good
brisket and it melts in your mouth
that's how you know it's really really
good exactly so we uh we sliced
everything to order everything's right
up down up front you got a a kitchen
right out there we do all the meat side
of the smokers we got two big offset
smokers we bought from Lockhart Texas it
was right out front so we're not hiding
anything man we're doing it all right
there we love it from scratch we've got
ribs too we do so uh classic ribs a
little bit a little more spice on those
ones we do have a little bit of a little
secret blend of some cayenne paprika and
some other spices we do pulled pork uh
we do smoked turkey we do a pork belly
with rubbed with coffee so we do some
unique stuff Beyond just the kind of
classical Texas stuff what do you hear
what's the feedback you get what is the
most popular item on your menu I mean
brisket is always yeah anything is that
that's for every person who comes to a
barbecuation if you do it right yeah
outside of that I mean mac and cheese
that we do we make our own pasta Chef
Bruce is uh got a former Italian History
so we make all we make our own noodles
make our own cheese so I also make
everything so this is a corn casserole
we do which is kind of his plan like a
cornbread uh we do some lighter things
as well this is a cucumber and tomato
salad that we're doing this time of year
just because it's so you know nice and
light uh classic coleslaw as well so but
we mix it up we'll do some awesome
nachos with uh smoked chicken we'll do
you know anything and everything we kind
of just let the barbecue be the palette
and we'll color in from there all right
so Fourth of July can do the liver we uh
we do for most of the places down
locally and then you crack up as well
okay or something like that too if you
want okay Richard camerato Soul belly
barbecue with soul bellybbq.com is that
right all right thanks so much for being
here happy Independence Day to you
Jillian save me a